-Thank you, everybody,
for tuning in
and watching "The Tonight Show."
I appreciate it.
Let's get to the news
and jokes.
Well, guys, today
is September 17th.
I point that out
'cause, once again,
President Trump has contradicted
one of his medical experts.
I didn't want you to think
tonight's show was a rerun.
That's right, yesterday,
the director of the CDC,
Robert Redfield,
testified before Congress,
and he was asked
when a COVID vaccine
would be available
to the public.
Here's what he said.
-If you're asking me, when is it
gonna be generally available
to the American public
so we can begin
to take advantage of vaccine
to get back to our regular life,
I think we're probably looking
at third -- late second quarter,
third quarter 2021.
-Trump's staff saw that
and was like,
"Better put on
another pot of coffee.
It's gonna be a long one
tonight."
Meanwhile, Americans looked at
their sweatpants and were like,
"Guess it's gonna be me and you,
buddy, for a little
while longer.
Here we go."
Let me put this in perspective
for the Netflix generation.
By the time there's a vaccine,
the students at Cobra Kai
will be older than Mr. Miyagi.
Later that day, Trump was asked
about Redfield's
vaccine comments.
And check out what he said.
-I think he made a mistake
when he said that.
It's just incorrect information.
And I called him,
and he didn't tell me that,
and I think he got the message,
maybe, confused.
-He got the message
maybe confused.
Man, could Trump sound
any more like a mob boss?
"Yeah, this guy Redfield,
maybe he don't know so good.
Capisce?"
[ Laughter ]
Next he's gonna send Eric
and Don Jr. with baseball bats
down to the CDC.
"It looks like you,
uh, misremembered,
and maybe we can help
jog your memory."
The head of the CDC
was confused.
Trump was like, "The vaccine
is right around the corner,
according to my experts Chuck
Woolery and the My Pillow guy."
You know, as we speak,
Dr. Redfield is being led
into the White House basement,
where there's just
a pullout couch
and Dr. Fauci.
At the same press conference,
Trump said something
pretty shocking
about the number of COVID cases
in the United States.
Listen to this.
-If you take
the blue states out,
we're at a level
that I don't think anybody
in the world would be at.
-"Also, if you don't count the
racial tension and the economy,
it's been a pretty smooth
six months.
Wouldn't you say?"
Then Trump was like, "And if you
also take out the red states,
boom, we have no cases at all.
So, basically, no virus."
You can't just not count
certain states.
That's like eating a salad
for lunch,
a cheeseburger for dinner,
then saying,
"If you don't count the burger,
I'm vegan."
All this COVID stuff
is so depressing.
Do we have any lighter
Trump news?
-CNN has learned
the Trump administration
considered using a heat ray
against protesters
in Lafayette Park back in June.
The heat ray makes people feel
like their skin is on fire.
-I'm sorry, what? A heat ray?
Who are his advisors,
a bunch of minions stacked
on top of each other?
Even Kim Jong-un was like,
"That's pretty messed up, dude."
A heat ray. Apparently,
Trump ripped out a page
of an X-Men comic and was like,
"This."
But despite everything
that's going on,
Trump spent the morning
complaining about
Twitter's trending page.
Yeah, he believes trends
are rigged against him.
I don't know about that,
but I do think that, sometimes,
seeing a hashtag doesn't
tell the whole story.
So, we decided to take a look
at what's trending
and, more importantly, why.
I'll show you what I mean.
First up, Snuffleupagus
was trending.
You may think it's 'cause of
"Sesame Street's"
"Back to School" town hall.
But Snuffleupagus
is actually trending
'cause it's how Trump kept
pronouncing "Stephanopoulos."
Next up, cocaine was trending.
You may think it's 'cause
a cocaine ring
was busted in Brooklyn.
But cocaine is actually trending
'cause
it's what Red Lobster uses
for the salt rim
on their Dew-Garita.
[ Laughter ]
Up next, Emergen-C was trending.
You may think it's 'cause people
are preparing for a second wave.
But Emergen-C is actually
trending 'cause
it's what Trump's been using as
makeup since the virus started.
And, finally, 10.9 inches
was trending.
And you may think it's 'cause
it's the size
of Apple's new iPad.
But 10.9 inches is actually
trending 'cause of Chris Evans.
That --
I didn't even know --
I didn't even get to --
[ Cymbal crashes ]
[ Chuckles ]
"Maybe I could jog your memory
a bit."
Toothpick.
-No.
-Check this out. Today, there's
a pretty big announcement
from President Obama.
Listen to this.
-Former President Barack Obama
this morning announcing
that he will be releasing
his Presidential memoir.
It will come in not one
but two parts.
The first volume,
"A Promised Land,"
will hit bookshelves on
Tuesday, November 17th.
-Yeah, "A Promised Land"
is the first of two volumes.
And get this -- volume one,
this is real --
is 768 pages.
Wow.
Meanwhile, Trump already claimed
he read both volumes last night
and it was "boring."
768 pages.
That's not a coffee table book.
That's a coffee table.
768 pages. That's like my new
book plus another 760 pages.
[ Laughter ]
I actually plan
on buying both volumes
just in case I ever need to
block myself from a heat ray.
The heat ray!
This is interesting.
I saw that Amazon
has launched a new invite-only
section of its site
called Luxury Stores.
That's nice. Now you can order
a $5,000 Oscar de la Renta gown
and then have the package
hurled over your fence.
Yeah, it's about time
you can order a designer dress
that comes in the same box
as your Ragu sauce
and Lucky Charms.
And finally, a bus passenger
in the U.K. --
did you see this -- he came up
with a pretty interesting way
of protecting himself
from the virus.
Watch this.
-In other news, a man in England
was spotted on a public bus
using a live snake
wrapped around his head
as a COVID facemask.
-Meanwhile,
the guy was screaming,
"Somebody help me.
Help! Help me!"
You know someone's on Facebook
still like,
"You know, you got to use
the snake to cover your mouth
and your nose."
Unfortunately, chaos erupted
when another guy put a mouse on
as a facemask.